right-hander joe kelly for the los
angeles dodgers a little bit of a opener
situation here expected to see the young
lefty julio aureus after tommy lastella
leads off that's lying down the right
field line for a base set extra bases a
lead off double for tommy lestella and
that'll bring up ravi grossman breaking
wall hammered to left center a long run
and bellager can't get it scoring is la
stella grossman into second base that's
a double and the a's right off the top
have a one-nothing lead now marcus
simeon coming up and a 3-2 breaking ball
low
and simeon walks double-double walk to
open up the ball game still nobody out
and jake lamb will come in that's a
bouncing ball to second softly hit
hernandez has one play looks at first
and kelly finally gets the first out of
the night
second and third one out here's kenna
first pitch
driven to center
bellinger's got it grossman tags
grossman's going to score and simeon
tags up goes to third and the throw goes
into the dodgers dugout and that will
allow simeone to come in and score
so it's three nothing the a's lead
28 years old originally from valparaiso
indiana first round pick of the kansas
city royals they traded into oakland for
ben zobrist that's leads things off
bouncy ball deep short backhand by
simeon straightens up pros to first it's
dug out by canna and betts is out 6-3
and seeger is coming up attacks the
first pitch bangs the base hit to right
boy is he hot or what over the last four
games look he hit like 5 29. one on one
out here's justin turner ground ball
left side lunging played by lamb but
unable to get to his feet turner is it
more with an infield head extending the
on base group to 27 games
dodgers threatening to answer right back
after oakland gets three in the top of
the first dodgers have him at first and
second one gone for max muncie breaking
ball is swung on hit to right field
going back but scotty has a plane he
makes the catch runners get back muncie
is out that'll bring up will smith
fastball swung on popped up right side
lastella the second baseman in a short
right he's called off by biscotti and
steven makes the catch and mania works
out of it julio urias who has started
each of his first 10 appearances this
season but comes out of the pen tonight
figures to get the majority of the
innings got him swinging two up and two
down and now here comes marcus simeon
and a fastball is popped up foul
through the right side will smith sheds
the mask makes the catch and a one two
three inning for urias see just start in
the third so seeger's toothache now
justin turner bouncing ball to third
lambda's second one a juggle and a throw
to first and time but dropped marcano is
making his first start of the season at
first base couldn't hang on to it the
dodgers catch a break here see if muncie
can make it hurt his first home run
since september 4th last night high fly
ball to deep right field biscotti back
at the wall
mercy with home runs and back-to-back
games
that thing touched the clouds
the a's left the door open and coming
crashing through are the dodgers and the
a's lead is now 3-2 third inning of work
coming for julio urias who's walked one
but not giving up a hit ramon l'oreal
leads it off went around and the
strikeout opens the fifth second
strikeout for urius got him over the
tenth strikeout of the season for tommy
stella 12 pitch inning for riaz bookend
case first and second one away here's
the eight hitter ramon loriano he's old
for two tonight chokes up and he pulls
it on the ground through the left side
of base it rbi single for laureato that
extends the a's lead to 4-2 mana has
retired seven in a row dodgers don't
have a hit since muncie's homer in the
third jodie ballinger leading off this
seventh it's a fly ball to right center
field sends biscotti back out
now it's a 4-3 game on bellinger's 12.
so six plus innings for sean monae he's
gonna leave with a four to three lead
what a season jake beekman is having 18
and a third no runs edwin rios for his
first played appearance
ripped down the line to right hooking
towards
[Applause]
the first run allowed by jake diekmann
all season is coming up against their
old friend blake shrinen so up to
l'oreal to try and drive in the go ahead
run for oakland that one's hit to left
field down the line
and
that baby is gone lauriano has hit it
out and the a's take a six to four lead
that is huge oh is that big so now the
ace can go to their closer liam
hendricks blew the save on opening day
but it's been perfect since then the
dodgers are down to their last one lined
toward grossman he
goes into a slide he makes the catch and
that's the ball game and the a's get a
good win